good morning believe nation today's
message is don't waste your minutes over
to you Bob Proctor awake
TV go how many times have you had
somebody say to you or have you got a
minute Bob we got a minute then one
minute would you think about that I read
a poem one time I said I have only just
a minute only 60 seconds and it was
forced upon me I can't refuse it I
didn't seek and I didn't choose it but
it's up to me to use it I must suffer if
I lose it
give a count if I abused it it's only a
tiny little minute but eternity isn't it
well any rate I thought I'm going to put
this on a video I'm just going to share
with everybody just this one little part
out of the seminar I'm making I want you
to look at this Sam timer and let this I
want you to think about your life the
sand in the top of the glass represents
the future the sand and the bottom of
the glass represents the past now you
know we know what's in the past and
young we can't do anything about it you
know what the trick is you don't know
how much sand is in the top of the glass
you may think you have a lot you might
only have a little then again you may
think you have a little and you might
have a lot when I was a little boy I was
raised by my grandmother and I don't
know when I was little gaffur she would
probably 60 but as long as I could
remember redwood saying I'll soon be
gun-deer I'll soon be gone well you know
we loved her she was really an angel of
God but we thought she was never going
to go she lived to be 94 for 30-some
years I'll soon be gone she didn't think
she had much time left she had 34 years
left now about the same time I had a
buddy of mine Bob Yates he was just 16
and bang he run into the abutment of a
bridge and his life was snuffed out if
you had asked him a half-hour before how
much sand he had left he would have said
at least a half a century he didn't have
a half an hour see the trick is we don't
know how much sand we have left
the future we don't know the past it's
gone now the only thing you can deal
with is what's right here right now and
if you look the sand is always moving
now think of this you see I was working
on that and then I was working on a
graph I've got here at my computer and
I'm thinking of the time somebody said -
have you got a minute well they don't
really want a minute do you know if
you're earning $50,000 a year a minutes
42 cents 1/2 hour is $12.50 if we take
that ahead of it if you're earning
$80,000 a year a minute 67 cents half
hours $20 during a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year got a minute
in it it cost you a dollar twenty-five a
minute I half hours thirty seven dollars
and fifty cents so if you see if
somebody said you want to stop for a cup
of coffee well if you're earning a
quarter of a million dollars a year a
minute is two dollars and eight cents
half hours sixty two dollars and fifty
cents and then of course you've got the
coffee to pay for on top of that so do
you see the point is this this is all
we've got right here right now we don't
know how much we have left in the future
but we do know what we've got now and I
have found the people that win are the
people who make up their mind then I'm
going to waste the minutes they're going
to be productive they're going to make
it happen every minute as I watch Bob
I'm reminded of Ingvar Kamprad who's the
founder of Ikea and one of the things he
said that really left his mark on me was
he says to divide your life into ten
minute chunks and then waste as few of
those chunks as possible
divide your entire life every day that
you have into ten minute chunks and
waste as few of those chunks as possible
I think if you look at most people's
work days where they think they're
working you know most people work at a
job where they're working 9:00 to 5:00
they're probably only working three to
four hours of really being super
productive and there's a lot of waste of
time between lunch and checking Facebook
and just
downtime you're not actually working
that hard and if you want to have
success you do something meaningful and
have the greatest impact that you can
have you got to stop wasting as many of
those ten minute chunks as possible I
think in my life I'm pretty rigorous
errata I think it could be even better
honestly which would probably shock and
surprise the people who know me best you
have to deal with me in my time
management but I'm already putting
rigorous it's why I don't use a cell
phone because I don't want people
calling me I don't want people texting
me because it's not just answering that
phone call it's a distraction from what
I'm trying to do right it takes me out
of the zone of what I'm working on right
now I don't like going to most parties I
don't like going to most weddings I
don't like just hanging out with people
I want to go where I feel like I'm
having an impact right I'm motivated by
impact and so if I'm going to a wedding
and I feel like you know what nobody
really cares if I'm here or not
the bride and groom that I don't really
know don't really care if I'm here I
don't want to be there going to a party
if people don't really care if I show up
or not it's just a party I don't want to
be there like I want to make sure that
I'm spending my time and having an
impact on things now if you need me for
something if you if you're struggling
with a problem with your business in
your personal life I will drop
everything to come and help you because
again I'm motivated by the impact
sometimes I still end up going to
weddings because of you know family
commitments and not wanting to cause
conflict and strife but it still bothers
me it's still deep down inside bothers
me that that I'm wasting my time and so
I think I could still get better as
rigorous and as demanding as my schedule
already is but I would challenge you to
look at your schedule look at the work
that you're doing
how many 10-minute chunks are you
wasting how many times you get
distracted by things happening in your
life how many times you just chill
instead of actually getting some work
done and I think even if you don't work
any extra hours either you just take the
hours that you're currently working
because you still want to spend time
with family you still want to sleep you
still want to do your other activities
even whatever having it if you're
working 40 50 60 hours a week whatever
it is 70 80 100 just those current hours
look at that time frame I bet
could be way more productive than you
currently are
you're wasting way too many of those ten
minutes in your life and if you want to
go and have a big impact
you have to waste less of them so the
question day today is I'm curious where
are you wasting your time where are
those 10 minutes anks or those minutes
that you're wasting your time on you're
not being productive when you should be
productive where are you wasting your
time leave in the comments below I'm
gonna join in the discussion thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you see this brace okay go